now just to refresh your memory right I
said equals on one side which of the
following statements is true okay
most people quickly worked out it can't
be a because you're the module serves in
is wonders that is it's richer okay so
that's out
most people looked at this and probably
thought yeah that looks weird I'll just
skip that for a second and keep going
right people looked at this this is the
most common so we call these distractors
right this is the most common one that
people thought was the answer but it
wasn't okay what does this mean the
imaginary part of Zed right the
imaginary part is negative one it's the
size of the imaginary part right I is a
number it's not the actual part that's
attached to the number right so
therefore the Sears Sears a distractor
it's a decoy okay I said is not plan
forests well where is it it's a one - i
its - pine floor okay so then that
raised you back to B which is simply a
weird
admittedly but you can see my solution
here here is a is s web right here and
then you can see the one and the I
square they cancel which leaves you with
minus 2i right which actually doesn't
take that much intuition to think about
because here's one - I write these one
minute sign it shouldn't take that much
to think I can't weigh if that's pot the
mine is pine for right when you square
this guy that's what brings you down to
here and that's gonna be negative - you
can see you can see the real part is
gonna be zero okay so even though Part B
looks a bit weird more people should
have picked it they did okay i lucky you
you didn't have to do this question
because I am it a bit sir dodge ball
that one I'm three days I wants to say
really you you either understood okay
this is how I use the conjugate and what
it means or you miss up like I said you
misunderstood like what does that - lead
up what does that indicate on the are
get diagram right and lastly this
question here okay
again this is sticky I'll just tell you
this came out of an HSC right what's
thinking about this it says PI for pilot
three
you're thinking our ankles of course a
goes I'm really good at radians now
excite no one radians are
I'm awesome it's gonna be a goes gotcha
right so so pilot for plan three out
just not this we do use them to indicate
angles they're convenient but it's be
because how do I know it's be like I
should have actually seen that before I
even saw the plan for plans because it's
the modulus right so you're looking at
distances you want the distances to be
less sorry yeah great on this but less
than this right so that's why you get
this kind of shape by the way this is
called an annulus a special ring shape
or frisbee with a big hole in it you'll
make these when we do volumes by slicing
but clearly as soon as you saw that like
that absolute value the modules you can
ignore everything else okay and that's
happy was the answer
HSE question all right let's move a
little bit okay now I did say part a was
pretty straightforward so let me show
you what HUD says okay are you
calculating the modulus that was great
you added these two together that was
fantastic
you just have to multiply by the
conjugate some people multiplied by a
plus 6i by the conjugate of the you
grade I said of the denominator which
wouldn't have gotten you very far
because you wouldn't realize that he'd
be a large number of people got tripped
up by their accuracy here right so when
they went from here to here a
significant number of people for
instance they did eight plus eighteen so
they had a 26 or in here you know
they're their numbers didn't work out
and so they have 99 left over or
something like that again that's an
accuracy thing as an exam technique
lesson there by the way like you can see
this is the warm-up this is the water
question right it's just sort of
rhythmic it but just like in a real
actual warm-up it's really easy to get
injured before you are actually warmed
up or to get a question wrong before
your brains in gear okay
so there's a lesson for you the first
question is where the highest
concentrations of silly air is always
are every time right people get to the
end of the exam and their brains in gear
they don't get it or they make a mistake
because they actually don't handle it
the question but pretty much everyone
knows how to do this
okay come back - it doesn't matter if
it's abstention one or two you wereyou
regardless of a level always come back
to any questions part four okay let's
look again close off right now this is
the way I laid it out you didn't have to
lay it out exactly like this okay but
for those of you who just did it very
how to find the square root of a complex
number
pay attention okay you you say well I
want the square root of Omega right so
you call that any complex number because
the fundamental theorem of algebra tells
you that the square root incoming selva
is itself also a complex number okay so
that's right I'll just say it X plus iy
and then when you square both sides you
can start to get an equation where you
can equate the real and imaginary parts
okay once you go ahead you get two here
now a lot of people got a bit confused
at this point because you can see the
question says it here and started
hopeful it's almost question says find
the square root of Omega
given that the real part of the squared
Omega is greater than zero now what have
you took that is a remind up oh yeah I
remember what I'm sewing this pot here I
have to ignore x squared plus 1 because
x and y are real numbers X plus iy is a
complex number x and y are real numbers
so I think a lot of you thought oh cool
well I've taken care of that real bit no
worries I'm Dale I've dealt with that
but actually it really came down here
right it says the question says the real
pond is positive the real part is
positive which is why it makes sense to
go for X rather to go for y because once
you write the imaginary part you don't
know anything about that you get the
real part and then you say I only want
one of them right X is 3 only since I've
got this condition ok once you've got
that you get your negative 1 and don't
forget we'll see here again did it
pretty well but a number of you just
said I'll Exorcist and why is that good
for you you want a medal like you know I
want the complex number right to tell me
the square root of a Oh